bom dia meu nome é tabata amaral eu
tenho 24 anos e sou uma cientista
política e ativista pela educação o que
quer dizer que vem dedicando nos últimos
anos a lutar por uma educação de
qualidade entendendo que é assim que a
gente vai ter esse brasil com qual é
tanto sonho que é mais inclusivo
desenvolvido e ético
antes de começar eu queria fazer um
questionamento uma provocação a vocês eu
queria que cada um pensasse qual é a
meta qual é o propósito qual é o sonho
que move cada um de vocês o que faz
vocês acordarem cedo de manhã pegar o
ônibus bem apertado voltar à noite
estudar o que faz vocês estarem aqui
hoje no sábado buscando conhecimento
buscando novas idéias
o que move cada um de vocês nessa vida
essa é uma pergunta que pra mim foi
sempre muito importante e o que me move
é educação foi a educação que
transformou a minha vida e como eu quero
convencer vocês é educação que
transforma e realmente muda as coisas
mas antes de contar um pouco mais como
que eu cheguei nesse propósito e como eu
cheguei aqui hoje eu queria falar um
pouco dessa área que tanto encanta mas
que ainda me indigna bastante a gente
vive em um país onde ainda hoje mais da
metade da população adulta não consegue
ler e entender um texto simples o que eu
estou dizendo para vocês pessoal é que
quando a gente pega 10 brasileiros sete
deles quando recebe o comunicado da
escola convidando para a reunião de pais
não entende o que está dizendo eu estou
falando para vocês que quando a gente
olha para 10 pessoas no brasil sete
delas não consegue entender texto
simples quanto mais lutar pelos seus
direitos na saúde educação moradia e por
aí vai
e quando eu olho pra esse dado o
primeiro questionamento que eu faço é
beleza
a gente fez um péssimo trabalho de
educar os nossos adultos
mas e as crianças e os jovens ea
resposta não é tão animadora ainda hoje
2 milhões de crianças e jovens estão
fora da sala de aula no brasil e aí sim
que dá mais raiva daqueles que estão na
escola pública que saem do ensino médio
apenas 20 de cada 100 ou dois de cada
dez estão aprendendo o básico em
português e apenas 3 de cada cem estão
aprendendo o básico e matemática
então é isso mesmo que vocês entenderam
a gente não educou a geração adulta a
gente ainda tem gente fora da escola e
quem está dentro não necessariamente
está aprendendo isso a grande maioria
está se tornando analfabeto funcional
como os nossos pais mas como nem tudo
nessa vida são dores
algumas coisas estão mudando e olhar
para a situação entendendo como a
educação realmente transforma e que a
gente não está priorizando isso no
brasil fez com que eu me envolvesse com
ativismo pela educação e nos últimos
quatro anos trabalhasse com o movimento
social chamado mapa educação
o mapa hoje no brasil inteiro e é um
movimento de jovens de coração e de
idade que lutam diariamente para que a
educação seja uma prioridade no brasil
para eleitores para candidatos e para
governantes a gente realiza conferências
debates e forma esses jovens para que
eles aprendam e entendam que a gente
consegue fazer muita pressão política do
ponto de partida de cidadãs e cidadãos
que somos
a gente já reverteu em uma cidade a
forma de selecionar os diretores saíram
de indicação política que é comum na
maioria das cidades do brasil
uma seleção pela comunidade escolar e
esse trabalho de ativismo nos três
setores
e essa luta diária pela educação foi me
mostrando que o caminho pra gente
realmente transformar as coisas no
brasil é o caminho da política e eu sei
que a política de hoje nunca gosto e eu
sei que não nos representa e dar
bastante raiva mas eu fui aprendendo que
a gente não pode deixar que a política
partidária que muitas vezes se traduz em
politicagem e tá tão polarizada nos
impeça de nos envolver com a política
pública porque a política pública que
pode pegar todas as teorias incríveis
que eu aprendi na universidade que pode
pegar as experiências mais bonitas que
houve no será no ceará de educação que
pode pegar todo o conhecimento que a
gente tem e transformar em realidade o
problema da educação no brasil
não é que as pessoas não sabem o que
fazer não é que a gente ainda não
entendeu qual é o caminho
o problema da educação da desigualdade
no brasil é que falta vontade política e
falta vontade política da nossa parte
nem comecei a falar dos governantes
então foi isso que me motivou agora está
trabalhando com outro movimento social
que é um movimento de renovação política
chamado acredito que é suprapartidário
que é nacional e que tem a missão nada
pequena de fazer com que as pessoas
voltem a acreditar no brasil voltem a
acreditar que o nosso país tem jeito que
a política pode ser diferente e que o
único caminho possível é esse então a
gente está em 14 estados
construindo uma agenda de combate à
desigualdade mas também convidando as
pessoas a fazerem política no dia a dia
e assim engajarem com as eleições
eu realmente espero que essa previsão de
que um terço dos eleitores do brasil
não vou votar esse ano não se cumpra
porque isso é realmente a gente se
entregar e dizer que a gente está
entregando nosso futuro
o que a gente não se importa mais
pessoal contando um pouco pra vocês do
que ainda me motiva porque eu trabalho
em áreas que podem ser bastante
desmotivadoras porque quando eu olho
para a educação quando eu olho para a
política
pouca coisa mudou nas últimas décadas
nem nos últimos anos mas contando pra
vocês um pouco do que me trouxe até que
eu espero mostrar o quanto de esperança
eu tenho eu tenho muita razão para ter
esperança e pra saber olhar para o
futuro e dizer cara mudança está
chegando
não é que vai chegar não começou já a
minha mãe é do interior da bahia ela
veio para são paulo para tentar estudar
e chegando no ensino médio grave 2min e
como a gente sabe que uma sociedade como
a nossa uma mulher que engravida
solteira um é nada acolhida e não foi
diferente com minha mãe ela teve que
sair do emprego ela parou de estudar e
foi parar na vila missionária
eu espero que alguns de vocês conheçam
fica pertinho da represa billings perto
do abc periferia da zona sul de são
paulo
ela foi morar com meu pai um terreno de
ocupação nesse bairro que nos acolheu
que fica longe mas é melhor que messi da
região e foi lá que a gente começou a
nossa vida
foram muitas dificuldades mas na
educação encontrei uma grande
oportunidade
eu participei das olimpíadas de
matemática da obmep e com isso ganha uma
bolsa escola privada e mais do que mais
oportunidades
essa olimpíada' me mostrou um mundo que
eu nem sabia que existia
eu comecei a conviver com pessoas que
falavam inglês espanhol pessoas que
sonhavam em fazer faculdade coisa que
nem se discute na minha casa pessoas que
tinham sonhos pra si e não é que eu
tinha um sonho pequeno pra mim não tinha
nenhum sonho mesmo e foi morando nesse
outro mundo que não era nem outro país
no centro de são paulo 45 horas por dia
porque as outras quatro eram no
transporte que eu comecei a me provocar
o que me motiva qual que é o meu sonho
qual que é o meu propósito é o meu
primeiro sonho estava nas ciências
eu queria ser cientista e foi assim que
eu fui pra cinco olimpíadas mundiais de
ciências e comecei a sonhar com fazer
faculdade nos estados unidos a barreira
do inglês que eu não falava só fui
aprender na faculdade a barreira
financeira
quase me fizeram desistir sonho muitas
vezes mas tinha tanta gente sonhando
comigo que deu certo
eu fui para os estados unidos foi para
harvard fazer a minha faculdade
mas no meio do caminho aconteceu uma
coisa que realmente fez a entender que
meu propósito não era ser cientista
estava na educação pública estava na
política
quatro dias depois que eu fui aceito em
hardware e depois em outras faculdades
americanas
eu perdi meu pai às drogas e para o
álcool e eu estou contando isso pra
vocês porque naquele momento eu entendi
que não importasse o quanto eu ganhasse
dinheiro no futuro o quanto o isolasse e
morasse no edifício mais alto de são
paulo
a desigualdade sempre bateria na minha
porta sempre e foi por isso que quando
eu falei não vou sempre os estados
unidos
mesmo com toda a dor que estou sentindo
eu sabia que eu ia para depois voltar
porque o brasil era meu lugar e era
através da educação que só áreas como a
do meu pai de um cara extremamente
inteligente que mesmo sem ensino
fundamental lhe escrevi e gostava de
matemática para que histórias de pessoas
como a dele não terminem dessa maneira
os 39 anos de idade eu tinha que voltar
então fui fazer faculdade me formei em
ciência política e astrofísica que é uma
combinação pouco estranha mas tenho
muito claro que era através da educação
era através desse engajamento que eu ia
permitir que pessoas como meu pai
pudessem realmente ser e sonhar e fazer
o que quisesse
independente de onde nasceram
independente da cor
independente do gênero e foi dessa
maneira
eu voltei para o brasil e comecei o
ativismo que eu contei pra vocês
e aí pessoal queria fazer uma nova
provocação
talvez alguns de vocês estejam pensando
olhando pra vocês não está barata a
educação transforma vidas mas país
será que transforma mesmo e aí eu queria
compartilhar uma história que pra mim é
uma das maiores provas que transforma o
país inteiro sim talvez vocês saibam
disso
no continente africano tem uma prática
que é muito forte culturalmente mas que
mata milhares de mulheres todos os anos
que a mutilação genital feminina já
ouviram falar
pois bem essa é uma prática que é muito
difícil de combater
tem a ver com a cultura tem a ver com a
religião é muito antiga e diferentes
organizações falharam tentando combater
a mutilação genital feminina
até que chegou a molly melting que é uma
ativista americana que depois de morar
30 anos no senegal começou uma pequena
revolução e sabe como ela fez isso ela
não chegou lá e falou vocês são
ignorantes
isso é certo e errado o caminho não é
por aí
ela foi um trabalho de formiguinha
educando as mulheres das vilas e quando
eu digo edu cano ensinando a ler e
escrever e depois foi levando discussões
sobre direitos humanos e pronto
a revolução tinha começado essas
mulheres empoderadas do conhecimento
começaram a ver que aquela prática ea
contra os direitos humanos da sua
vizinha da sua neta da sua filha se
uniram e fizeram com que o senegal fosse
o primeiro país a abandonar mutilação
genital feminina
e aí pessoal se isso não motiva vocês
realmente acreditarem que o caminho da
transformação do nosso país é pela
educação porque assim a gente mata
pessoas no brasil por ignorância
eu não sei o que mais motiva pra mim dá
muita energia muita coragem de saber que
é uma caminhada
longa mas que é uma caminhada muito
possível e um dos questionamentos que eu
mais me faço é eu sei que está ruim
eu sei que a gente está desanimado eu
sei mesmo e sei que dói muitas vezes só
que se não for a gente vai lá e pegar o
nosso futuro de volta
se não for a gente a começar a
questionar e trazer a mudança que a
gente vem lutando há tanto tempo
quem mais vai ser então a gente está
aqui não porque estamos brigando por
esse espaço mas porque não tem ninguém
então o meu convite pra vocês é
realmente pensarem e sabe se
questionarem diariamente o que me traz
até aqui
qual o meu propósito nessa vida e meu
propósito e envolve outras pessoas
porque pra mim propósito é um sonho que
a gente sonha e constrói junto com os
outros e aí galera uma vez me disseram
que quando a gente é muito impactado por
uma fala mas muito mesmo
a gente tem faz algumas são nas próximas
duas horas
agora sim se for assim marrazzo que a
gente escutou a gente tem até quatro
horas para fazer alguma coisa como eu
quero ter muitos está muito segura eu
queria fazer um pedido para a próxima
uma hora
faltou colocar lá embaixo que vocês
realmente no intervalo nas próximas
palestras escrevessem no papel
o propósito o sonho grande a meta de
vida de cada um de vocês tem que ser na
próxima hora porque depois não vou
escrever que eu sei e aí eu queria logo
dizer quando a gente diz em voz alta o
nosso sonho que nos motiva
talvez um ou dois alçapões uma fila vai
criticar e sabe porquê uma fila vai
criticar porque a partir do momento que
você fala eu sonho com isso está dizendo
que isso é possível não só pra você mas
para quem está ao redor e se incomoda
tira as pessoas da zona do conforto
então sim vão criticar os sonhos e
propósitos de vocês mas usa isso como
combustível e quando eu olho pra esses
dados da educação quando eu olho para as
críticas que a gente recebe
é o que eu penso poxa tem gente
criticando é porque o sonho vale a pena
então de novo na próxima hora que depois
acaba energia
coloque no papel qual que é o propósito
de vocês e mais do que isso
qual é a minha contribuição para que o
nosso brasil seja mais inclusivo
desenvolvida economicamente e ético
estamos combinados posso contar com
vocês
então vamos junto que a mudança já
começou e a gente está com pressa até
mais brigada
[Aplausos]